i'm very sad to say that this is our
very last
bold type interview with e.t you guys
how are you feeling
well now i'm feeling sad oh actually
thank you so much but this is where you
stop
rude uh don't listen to that we've seen
the episode
this is all for afterwards let's dive
into
each of the characters endings
individually megan let's kick it off
with you
after a whole season actually multiple
seasons of
ups and downs between sutton and richard
they
ended up together after all this like
baby no baby maybe
talk what was your reaction to sutton's
ending and what do you think her life is
going to be like
after the show i am really thrilled with
the ending i'm super happy that sutton
and richard stayed together
it felt like the right thing for both of
those characters
sam and i were really vocal about that
the most interesting part of that story
i guess is that it wasn't written that
way
it was written that they didn't wind up
together and the night before we were
supposed to shoot that scene they
rewrote it and we shot it differently
and um i'll never forget getting the
phone call
that night from our showrunner saying we
changed it
and you guys are going to end up being
together and it was just like the best
feeling ever because
that was what we wanted so badly and we
totally understood why they were maybe
going to tell a different version of
that story
but we were really really pleased with
what ended up happening yeah that makes
me so happy
yeah it's like the payoff is really nice
i hope that the audience
really and what do you think sutton and
richard are up to
post the bold type show where do they
end up i think they move
uh upstate and jane and cat
are locked up in the basement so that
they can always be together forever and
they're just in a bathtub
in the basement jane tries to leave
and sutton offers to drive her to the
airport but takes a detour
locks her in a basement guys let's
celebrate we finally lived together
and i want to make it insta-official
asia kat was made the editor-in-chief
of scarlet magazine she's really come
full circle
and that's such a huge honor for her
what was your reaction to her ending and
what do you think
cat does next my first reaction
when they were like cat's gonna be
editor was
okay sure i truly didn't believe it
especially given that she was
just fired multiple times when you look
back on the series she's
constantly shown that she's a great
leader and that
she has experience being a manager and
i guess it kind of seems like it would
be an obvious choice for her but i
didn't see it coming
i don't think people watching the show
will see it coming either especially
given that it happens like halfway
through the finale it happens
it really comes out of nowhere but like
i consider myself a fan of the show
and so for me as a fan it was really
satisfying to see that president
thank you jacqueline for everything
that you and scarlett have given me and
what do you think she does next with
scarlett now that she's the big
boss in charge well other than living in
richard's
remotely she doesn't need to leave the
basement she kind of has like a
stockholm syndrome thing going on
like i love my chapters like i'm
actually
so much better off being than in the
real world i guess in my mind
maybe adina and cat like adopt some
babies and like
you know i can just see them being great
mothers and having like a big home with
lots of kids a lot
the vibe that's really cute jacqueline i
need to talk to you
katie i did not see jane's ending coming
she worked so hard to prove that she's a
great mentor to her writers
and then at the end of the finale we
find out not only is she quitting
scarlett but then she's gonna go travel
what was your reaction to her ending i
was excited when they first told me
about it
because i was like yes send this type a
need to let go girl on an eat pray love
journey
and i think the whole point is that she
you know wants to
learn about other cultures and feminism
and other countries and
you know what that looks like she's been
in her sort of safe little bubble for so
long but i think that
the beauty behind that growth is that
we've seen jane go through so much
and so much of what she's done is
in plans for her future to give herself
time
to give herself a healthy future and
i'm happy that we're telling a story of
somebody who's not just
burying themselves in their work or just
taking the next step because it feels
like
that's the one they should take and
making a decision that feels incredibly
difficult but ultimately
is a reflection of her own self-love and
her own journey of self-discovery that
she needs to go find this is my time
to live in the moment and take risks
where do you think she goes next if she
gets out of sutton's basement
i'm sure that richard have a very nice
basement i
feel like she probably bought a ticket
and went and traveled somewhere
maybe wrote some stories about things
that she
learned about in the places that she
goes to maybe had like a hot european
fling for a second
i was going to say i think you come back
with a husband like an italian husband
yeah with the last name giovanni yes
oh wait that's fine sorry it's your
dream
i thought it was really sweet that you
guys did the screaming scene where
you're wearing the same color coats as
dresses in the first episode
what was it like for you guys to revisit
that moment
honestly really yeah because i guess
like i just didn't feel like it's that
long ago like we were doing it and in my
mind i was like oh this was like a good
chunk of years ago during it i was like
this feels like it was
a couple episodes ago like it was last
block or whatever it felt very familiar
and like a kind of sense of the process
dreaming in a public place
is very freeing yeah there's something
like visceral about it because it's such
a specific thing to recreate
any of us have done that since we did it
the first time so it really does take
you like right back
to that feeling which was kind of
incredible
if down the line there were an
opportunity to reunite
the three of you and play your
characters again would you
be interested in doing it or are you
happy putting it to bed
i mean everyone knows i would do it any
if anybody told me that i would have the
chance again to
be the three amigos again in some sense
but i think that like there are
conditions
such as you know it would have to be
filmed in new york with the three of us
maybe a couple years from now i would
like it to be a movie
like i think we're all happy to like put
like
the tv show itself to bed but like i'd
be down to just like do a movie just to
see
where they're at you got this thank you
for being here
to scarlett
you